AJA HAMMERLY: Welcome
to Cloud Minute.
Today I'm going to show you
how to enable and disable
APIs on Google Cloud Platform.
If you are trying
to use a GCP product
but are receiving an
unauthorized error,
you should double-check
that the API is enabled.
On GCP you have to enable the
API that you want your project
to use.
From Google Cloud console,
click API Manager and then
Enable API.
You can search for the
API you need to enable.
I'm enabling the Cloud
Natural Language API.
On the details page you can see
more information about the API,
access the documentation, or
enable or disable the API.
Once it is enabled I can
use the API from my code.
I can also see information
about my usage and any errors
I've received on this page.
If you want to see all the
APIs in use on your project,
click on the dashboard.
If you need to disable
any of these APIs,
you can do that from here.
That's it.